OK.
We were speaking earlier about killing grandma
to save the stock market.
Essentially the calculation that Donald Trump
seems increasingly comfortable making and
erring on the side of the stock market instead
of grandma.
Texas Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick says
that many grandparents like him are willing
to die to save the economy for their grandchildren.
And if nothing else, this pandemic has really
exposed how incompetent and immoral or amoral
so many people in positions of power are.
So now I bring you a segment from Fox News
propagandist Tucker Carlson's program where
Dan Patrick makes.
Is this a patriotic argument?
Is that what he's calling it, that.
It's a patriotic case for letting it rip.
Living in fear of is what's happening to this
country.
And you know, Tucker, no one reached out to
me and said, as a senior citizen, are you
willing to take a chance on your survival
in exchange for keeping the America that all
America loves for your children and grandchildren?
And if that's the exchange, I'm all in.
And that doesn't make me noble or brave or
anything like that.
I just think there are lots of grandparents
out there in this country like me.
I have six grandchildren that what we all
care about and what we love more than anything
are those children.
And I want to, you know, live smart and and
see through this.
But I don't want the whole country to be sacrificed.
And that's what I see.
I've talked to hundreds of people, Tucker,
and just in the last week and I'm making
calls all the time and and everyone says pretty
much the same thing, that we can't lose our
whole country.
We're having an economic collapse.
I'm also a small business man.
Understand it.
And I talked with business people all the
time, Tucker.
And and I'm so my I'm just my heart is lifted
tonight by what I heard the president say,
because we can do more than one thing at a
time.
We can do two things.
So, you know, my message is that let's get
back to work.
Let's get back to living.
Let's be smart about it.
And those of us who are 70 plus, we'll take
care of ourselves.
That's a sick so-called pro-life Republicans
saying let's let the grandparents die so that
we don't sacrifice the economy, by which they
really don't mean the economy.
They mean the stock market.
And the funniest or the craziest or sort of
the most tragic thing about all of this is
that he and Trump, they're all talking about,
let's go back to doing stuff, 30 of 50 states
roughly have done nothing or almost nothing.
In other words, they want 30 states to go
from having done nothing anyway to continuing
to do nothing while the other 20 states, including
places that are significant hotspots, would
have to take what would have to choose a path
that would lead to significantly more death.
It's only been like a week where I'm like
eight days in now to the self-isolation.
And we've already got Trump and others saying,
let's let more
old folks die in order for the stock market
to recover, in order to not take as big of
a GDP hit as what we are in undoubtedly going
to take in order to prevent as big of an unemployment
increase as we clearly are going to see on
April 3rd, when the March unemployment numbers
are announced.
It's essentially a death panel.
Remember back when Sarah Palin and other Republicans,
when Obamacare was being negotiated, they
said Obamacare has death panels where politicians
get to decide if you live or die, if what
you need does or doesn't get paid for.
Now, at the time, we pointed out this is absurd.
We already have death panels which are called
insurance companies.
Insurance companies already decide is this
treatment or that treatment considered medically
necessary?
Does this treatment or does that treatment
get covered by insurance?
We already had.
What
is it?
And continue to have what is essentially a
death panel.
But the more absurd part of this is they're
essentially saying we've decided some old
people have to die.
It's a death panel to save the economy, by
which they mean the stock market.
How is this going to play, by the way, with.
News's own disproportionately older audience.
I mean, you know, in all seriousness, I'm
I'm wondering about that.
And then moreover, you know, Lieutenant Governor
of Texas, Dan Patrick, if he wants to sacrifice
himself, maybe there's something to talk about.
But he's deciding for other people, he's deciding
we should sacrifice lots of grandparents for
the sake of the economy and the economy for
our grandchildren.
As he says, it's actually almost cultists
surrender your life to the Trump stock market,
which now, by the way, is a net decline.
Donald Trump's major accomplishment,
as he claimed for the first three years of
his presidency, was that the stock market
now all along, we knew that stock market growth
under Obama had actually been better, stronger,
bigger than under Donald Trump.
Now he doesn't have that.
And you've got people like Dan Patrick saying,
I would sacrifice myself and many grandparents
would volunteering essentially unknown and
faceless grandparents as he knows them or
doesn't know them in order to save the economy.
Meaning pump the stock market.
So Trump can claim that he did something for
the country while he was president.
It sounds very much like the opposite of small
government deciding to sacrifice grandma for
the stock market.
But of course, it seems that that is no longer
the priority
of
small government conservatives.